You mean I have to wash my hands every day...
...to get rid of the germs that can make me sick?
Sheesh, you have to wash your hands more than once a day!
Germs hide in all kinds of places like cellphones, pets, countertops, doorknobs,...
...and of course, in the bathroom too.
So, you're telling me pretty much anything we touch...
...can have bacteria and viruses on them?
And those germs can get onto your hands?
Then, into your body through your mouth and nose to make you sick.
Makes sense.
That's why it's so important to wash your hands often throughout the day.
Especially after using the bathroom and before eating.
And don't forget after blowing your nose or coughing.
Spit and snot aren't the only things that can fly out...
...and tissues don't catch it all.
I guess you can never get rid of germs...
...but you can outsmart them by washing your hands.
Even you can be smarter than any germ.
It's you we need to worry about.
It's not enough just to wash your hands often.
You need to do a good job of it, too.
You have to scrub your hands well if you want to wash away the germs...
...because they like to hide.